a lawsuit accuses a popular brand of
sparkling water of misleading customers
by calling its product natural the suit
accuses the Kois parent company national
beverage corporation of using non
natural flavorings and synthetic
compounds the company denies these
allegations but it comes as a growing
number of foods promoted as natural face
criticism Anna Warner is here with
what's at stake for companies and
consumers too and a good morning to you
well good morning well there's no
official government guidelines as to
what qualifies a product as natural
there's no denying the word is an
effective marketing tool Consumer
Reports says 73 percent of customers
actually seek out foods labeled as
natural the question is what are they
actually getting Lacroix says it's
sparkling water sales are bubbling over
up 17% last year
it's touted as a natural sodium and
calories free alternative to soda but a
new lawsuit alleges those natural claims
are false
it says synthetic chemical compounds are
added to Lacroix to make the drink taste
or smell a certain way the suit claims
one ingredient causes kidney tumors and
another is used as a cockroach
insecticide nutritional scientist Roger
Clemens says however the compounds are
considered safe these compounds are
found in nature mostly in fruit such as
oranges lime strawberries pineapples
bananas so we consume those compounds
every day if we any kind of fruit but it
will be up to a jury to determine
whether those compounds found in La
Croix are derived from natural
substances or are created artificially
parent company national beverage
corporation says the ingredients are
derived from the natural essence oils
from the named fruit used in each of the
flavors and are certified by our
suppliers to be 100% natural still the
labeling is part of a larger problem
because there's no industry standard as
to what the word means
I believe the consumer today are
confused with the word natural they
believe natural means safer natural
means or more wholesome one analysis
predicts continued explosive growth in
US sales of
so-called natural products reaching 252
billion dollars by next year but there
have been a reported 300 Lots over the
use of the word on food products in the
last three years in one 2016 settlement
General Mills was forced to drop the
word natural from its granola bars
packaging so if the consumers can't
figure this out now we have to didn't
over to the FDA and that their group of
scientists figure out what is a workable
natural definition so people could be
comfortable with that definition so they
call it buy into it
well the Food and Drug Administration
says of course it doesn't comment on
pending lawsuits the organization has
been studying this issue for three years
now but still has not come up with a
definition and scientists say it'll be a
tough test come up with language that
satisfy satisfies both the food
companies and the consumers viana you
got a lot of Lucroy drinkers at this
table a no we expect more investigative
work from you on this story and thank
you whether this lawsuit is bogus yeah
exactly